hello everyone
and welcome to the precision medicine
track on day two of the apj
genetics solution tour 2020. my name is
ryan harvey and i'm your moderator for
this session
this session will focus on the use of
axiom microarray technology for
precision medicine applications
including population scale genotyping
pharmacogenomics and developing a
polygenic risk score for alzheimer's
disease
just as a note if any questions arise
during the following presentations we
encourage you to submit them in the q a
box
our speakers will address your questions
following their presentations
first we will hear from shantanu
kushikar who is uh
the director for product marketing for
genotyping at denmark fisher scientific
shantanu is a part of the leadership
team that manages our commercial and r d
efforts for our microarray business
today shantanu will be providing you an
overview about how predictive genomics
is a powerful capability
to help predict disease risk and
understand drug response
in order to improve health outcomes and
manage costs
we will be talking about some of the
large-scale population genotyping
efforts implemented on the applied
biosystems
axiom microarray platform which we have
which have led to personalized health
health outcomes sorry
chanterelle will also be speaking about
how the axiom microarray platform has
been used to drive pharmacogenomics
initiatives for clinical research
welcome chanter
thank you the title of my presentation
today is predictive genomics
powering the future of population and
personalized
health predictive genomics is a powerful
capability to predict
disease risk and understand drug
response
in order to improve health outcomes and
manage costs
thermo fisher is at the forefront of
this wave of predictive genomics
where in the not so distant future
genomic testing
brings with it a greater opportunity for
managing disease
and improving health outcome
the accessibility of genomic content
from diverse populations
driven by government health systems and
industry is
accelerating the precise prediction and
diagnosis of disease
today clinical care explains about 15
percent of overall health outcomes
genetic data which is relatively easy to
measure
can add about 30 percent and this of
course is a huge opportunity
for us to influence health outcomes
and what genetic data helps to do is
stratify populations
target screenings optimize treatments
and tailor therapeutics based on a
person's biology
the uk biobank study where half a
million
samples were processed in the united
kingdom was the first to take the step
to integrate genomics to demonstrate
that integrating genomic data can add
value to understanding disease
and stratify populations the uk biobank
today has over 1100 publications
the genetic data for which was generated
on the axiom genotyping platform
today over 75 percent of the requests to
the uk biobank
are to access this genetic data so that
researchers can conduct meta-analysis
with newly generated data from the lab
laboratory
or to conduct their own research coupled
with deep phenotyping
rather than self-reported data data from
the axiom genotyping platform
has powered several revolutionary
discoveries and common diseases
as demonstrated by the publications from
the biobank
techniques to identify genetic risk in
populations such as polygenic risk
scores
are now becoming relevant because of the
power of these studies
and bringing health and wellness related
tests to the
clinic is becoming a reality the uk
biobank paper published in nature
demonstrated the utility of microarrays
for large population screening
initiatives
and also showed how imputation aware
designs could be adopted for populations
diseases
one of the outcomes of the uk biobank
has been to demonstrate the power of the
polygenic risk scores
previous sequencing initiatives have
attempted to catalog human genetic
variation
for example via the thousand genomes
project
these initiatives have demonstrated that
most of these variations will be
entirely benign
some may subtly impact on risk of
various common diseases
such variants with minor allele
frequency greater than one percent have
demonstrated that most people
are at risk from some sort of common
disease
such as diabetes obesity cardiovascular
disease to name a few
to offer the benefit of genetics to the
vast majority of the population
polygenic risk scores derived from
genetic data
can have predictive value for many
common diseases
a very small number of genetic variants
will have the potential to cause serious
genetic disorders
or disease either in an individual or in
their children
and are categorized as rare inherited
disorders
while polygenic risk scores are not new
the uk biobank demonstrated that with
the population skill initiative
polygenic risk scores can be developed
that would offer the
opportunity for asymptomatic at risk
individuals
to receive the appropriate management
that might have otherwise not been
considered
and also would reduce the amount of
diagnose over diagnosis
in health care systems
the paradigm for the future then is to
manage health
and not disease the early years of
genotyping
included several large studies
also on the axiom platform and included
studies such as the kaiser study that
was processed at university of
california in san francisco
over 100 000 samples were processed from
this study
other studies such as the uk biobank
with half a million
samples and are continuing today our
research focus
cohorts with the purpose of developing
deep insights into the genetic cause of
disease
these learnings are helping develop
outcome focus cohorts such as finjan
such as those used by the finnish
biobank
finjen and which is a collaborative
effort of the biobanks in finland
and are sparking new national
achievements in biomedicine
and predictive genomic tests to help
manage disease
our collaboration with med genome a
personalized medicine company has
produced a population optimized solution
that can be used to develop consumer and
predictive genomic tests
relevant to the south asian population
so it is necessary to develop polygenic
risk scores for each population
because the polygenic risk score is
unique and a single polygenic risk score
cannot be
applied across different population
groups this means developing a prs for a
population will require
screening of several million people to
help manage their health
and to be able to benefit from genetics
unlike any other whole genome technology
microarrays offer the capability to
genotype both rare
and common genotypes in several million
people
rapidly and cost effectively
axiom platform offers the ability to
customize
arrays and is built from fully
customizable
modular genetic modules these modules
allow you to tailor an array for your
research study
these modules include markers for
pharmacogenomics
for blood groups and blood phenotypes
and disease associated markers every
axiom array today includes a unique
imputation
aware gives grid that means
that markers chosen on the array provide
the most imputation power
and enables us to infuse the highest
number of markers for one or more
populations with the highest accuracy
other modules within axiom array include
disease
risk variants relevant to a wide range
of diseases
such as cancer cardiovascular and
cardiometabolic disease
neurological disorders alzheimer's
parkinson's etc to name a few
hla typing is available for studying
immunity and inflammation
and finally pharmacogenomics for
potentially adverse
for for learning about potential adverse
reactions
or sub-optimal daisy dosing based on the
latest genomic information
every array is fully customized with
content to match your products project
goals
and offers high value high utility
content
the finjan study that was mentioned
earlier uses the axiom platform
with the goal of developing better ways
to manage health
for 1100 disease endpoints
these inc these include diseases in
areas such as ophthalmology
neurology cardio metabolic disease
rheumatologic to name a few
syngen will genotype about 10 percent of
the population which is about half a
million people
from finland on axiom arrays by using
imputation
they are able to accurately reconstruct
the genomes of the fins
which are then combined with the
electronic health records from the
national health registry
by performing association analysis and
and meta-analysis
the goal of fingen is to move from
discovery to treatment and prevention
today over 250 000 samples have been
genotyped in about two years
and have enabled discoveries and
confirmation
in diseases such as diabetes
inflammatory bowel disease
asthma and macular degeneration
shenzhen selected microarrays and chose
thermo fisher scientific
because of our commitment to support
their efforts and genotyping with
microarrays
our ability to meet their goals of
improving health outcomes
in various disease endpoints for various
disease endpoints
within the lifetime of those that have
participated in this study
the fingering array is a fully
customized array with an imputation
aware design
and offers high genomic coverage in the
finnish populations
thermo fisher of also offered analysis
support
and customized solution with the ability
to redesign the array
and add markers to the array every year
the modular
diagram shown on the left slide
shows the modular construction of the
finished bionic array which includes
beyond the g beyond the g watts grid
other contents such as pharmacogenomic
content
disease causing variance variants
and variants that are implicated in
cardiac
cancer autoimmune and inflammatory
diseases
today predictive genomics incorporates
pharmacogenomic markers
on every array this includes both
investigative biomarkers
and valid biomarkers to learn about drug
drug and drug gene interactions
pharmacogenomics is integrated into our
custom and catalog arrays
in bio banking for population
stratification and pharmacogenomics
in preemptive pharmacogenomics for
clinical research and pharmaceutical
drug trials
the applied biosystems axiom
pharmacofocus and conocoscan arrays
are economical way to generate focused
pharmacogenomic data
the action platform is the only platform
that brings over 20 years of experience
in the field of pharmacogenomics to
address
markers in zero genes and complex
regions such as sip2d6
the pharmacofocus array that is shown
over here is a low-cost solution that is
available with over 2000
relevant pharmacogenomic markers and
integrated star allele calling
the array offers coverage of a wide
range of therapeutic areas
pharmacogenomic arrays such as
pharmacofocus include content that has
been selected
by consortium for their high evidence
and deep coverage of critical genes that
are relevant to pharmacogenomics
a unique assay the axiom
genotyping assay includes gene-specific
amplification
and makes possible the genotyping of
complex genes
or pseudogenes such as c2d6 c2c19
amongst others
the pharmacogenomic platform today is
deployed at multiple sites
one such collaboration is with the
university of pittsburgh in the
university of pittsburgh medical center
both upit and upmc have deployed the
platform to be able to look at hundreds
of genes
and to be able to offer preemptive
pharmacogenomics to the four million or
so patients
that are clearly enrolled in the upmc
healthcare system
the goal of utmc as mentioned by dr phil
mp the director of pharmacogenomics
is to select the best medication for
each patient based on their genes
and they have gone from one gene to
hundreds of genes
using the axiom pharmacogenomic platform
the university of pittsburgh or upmc
system
is our center of excellence and aims to
pre-emptively test
000 subjects in a real research study
and integrate the participants
pharmacogenomic profiles in the
electronic health records
to offer the right medication at the
right dose faster
starting with 4 million patients in the
catchment area of the upnc systems over
150
000 patients will be recruited into
their biobank with the goal of doing
preemptive pharmacogenomics in a
clinical workflow that includes
over 14 genes and
over 1200 and a research workflow that
includes 1200 pharmacogenes
that will form the basis of their
translational research
the goal is to show the value of true
population scale preemptive
pharmacogenomic testing
by delivering innovation and best
practices in the use of genomic data
this leads us to how will genomics be
used in the future
as i mentioned in my first few slides
genetic data can add 30 percent more
information to improve health outcomes
polygenic risk scores and
pharmacogenomics can then be combined
to help stratify the risk in population
and identify
drug response so that genetic testing
can offer the opportunity for
asymptomatic at-risk individuals
to receive the appropriate management
and the right drug at the right dose
that otherwise might not have been
considered
at thermo fisher scientific we continue
to invest in various r d initiatives to
help introduce
new whole genome capabilities cost
effectively and rapidly so as to make an
impact
in improving health outcomes this has
included capabilities in
pharmacogenomics
rare radiant analysis carrier screening
and more recently the axiom propelled
workflow to be able to screen over 2
million samples per year
our mission is to enable our customers
to make the world a healthier cleaner
and safer place
thank you
thank you for the great presentation
shantanu we have several
uh questions coming through now and the
first one we have here is
can pharmacogenomics further improve the
initiative of drug repurposing
in the treatment of covert 19.
um thanks ryan um uh yeah
so yes pharmacogenomics uh can certainly
improve
the initiative of drug repurposing uh
and we recently launched an array very
specifically for that
which is the axiom human genotyping sars
cove to array which has
more than six thousand pharmacogenomic
markers
the idea really was to understand the
drug drug and drug gene interactions
and to determine whether any of the
existing medications could be used
for the purpose of repurposing obviously
in a
research environment and then the
the same module which looks at the
the the sort of the pharmacogenomic
markers
also has radians to look at vaccine
development and vaccine research
so certainly pharmacogenomics can
improve the initiative of drug
repurposing
i hope this helps answers the question
and the array as i'm you know as
mentioned in the presentation uses the
gene-specific amplification step
which really looks at these critical
genes
thank you shantanu a couple other
questions that have come through here
how does the finnish biobank design
the genome coverage grid
i'm sorry could you repeat that again uh
uh
yeah how does the finnish biobank design
uh the genome coverage grid
oh so um we did um so the good question
that you know
the finnish biobank design was used in
imputation aware
uh design it basically uh they provided
us with several markers but we also
leveraged the thousand genomes
populations
and in addition to that thermofisher had
a um
has a large axiom database of validated
markers so these are verified markers
so we were actually able to design a
a finish specific biobank array
that had extremely high coverage and
accuracy
for the finnish population compared to
anything else that was available on the
market
great thank you and i guess uh playing
into that as well
what role does imputation aware
platforms
play uh in these population scale
projects
um so imputation aware designs
are a great way to design arrays
so we typically call them population
focused arrays and they are
designed then through a process called
imputation of their process
and we can design them for one or more
process the unique design capability at
thermal fissure
allows customers to capture
maximum number of common low frequency
and rare variants
that occur in the population and this is
done with
extremely high concordance and accuracy
so the arrays have higher performance
robust data quality for a variety of
research applications including
pharmacogenomics blood typing
where we are seeing increased
contribution from low and sometimes
rare alleles so all in all the
population specific arrays
designed through this imputation of
their design process really help
identify these important
associations and and allow for research
into more disease endpoints does that
help answer yes thank you
so another couple questions we have here
why are population genotyping projects
uh such as the tohoku meta mega bank
madcap uk biobank and finjin opting for
microarray as the platform of choice and
what value do they see in creating
customer raise for these populations
um yeah again another great question
from the audience uh ryan
so um the tohoku mega bar bank as you um
uh you know may be familiar with was
uh designed in japan by the tohoku mega
bio bank to study the japanese
population
the mat cap array if uh many people have
not heard about it was
a a cancer rig for prostate and other
cancers for african populations and then
of course the uk biobank
engine that i mentioned the reason for
designing these population or
specific arrays was really two-fold and
the population-specific arrays offer
higher statistical power and the ability
to conduct
large studies uh as mentioned in the
in my presentations and these are really
to help identify these important disease
associations and allow for research into
more
disease endpoints a second reason for
designing these population arrays
specific arrays is with the goal of
calculating polygenic risk scores for
these populations and
we know that now the polygenic risk
score is unique to a population
so by capturing the genetic diversity
and effect sizes
using variants that are relevant to the
population in these studies
the arrays are able to overcome the
eurocentric biases
and they avoid interrogating sort of the
monomorphic variants that are typically
observed in
generic sort of the general purpose
catalog arrays which are typically
marketed as suitable for
global screening so really the goal is
to make these important scientific
discoveries
and avoid missing out on important
associations
that's the reason for designing
population-specific areas
great thank you and on a similar sort of
note here another question we have is
in the ngs era why the work uh
why are these projects intended towards
microarray data instead of rna-seq or
whole exome sequencing
um so um uh
can you repeat the last part of the
question again right yes so in the ngs
era
why is the work uh that has been done
here tending towards microarray i guess
instead of uh
instead of next-gen sequencing oh yeah a
good question so yeah so
first thing microwave you know it's the
simplicity and ease of use as well as
the cost
uh you can certainly run large numbers
of studies as i mentioned you know we've
already you know the finjan has already
done 250 000 samples in two years
already has started to publish papers um
in on polygenic risk scores but really
it comes down to the data robustness and
in the age of
ngs you know there's certainly
more discussions around whether low pass
sequencing can be used or
just whole genome sequencing both of
these
especially the low pass sequencing leads
to quite a bit of missing data
it has challenges in data
robustness depends a lot on imputation
so if you don't have your populations in
your imputation panel
or if you don't have a good reference
genome which is very true for
anything that is not european then
connection sequencing is certainly not
attractive and you want to be able to
cover these studies very quickly
so microarrays are really the choice
of technology for running these
large-scale studies
and it provides this comprehensive
solution right so you want to be able to
look at pharmacogenomics
you want to be able to look at regions
of hoa so you know
looking at immunity and information for
example
you want to look at genes very specific
pathways rare variants
which are increasingly having higher
effect sizes in polygenic risk scores
for example
and so this makes the microarray
platform uniquely suitable for these
large-scale population studies and
that's you know really
the being able to sort of screen
large numbers of people within these
countries is extremely important if you
want to benefit from genetics
great thank you and the final question
we have here as well is
is there any uh particular advantages of
different uh or
disadvantages between the axiom platform
and other competitors in the market in
the microarray area
yeah so good point again um you know uh
the the two points really that i would
like to call out
first one is i already mentioned and uh
earlier which is the way we design these
arrays is extremely unique
uh these are the imputation aware
designs um
that thermo fisher has a very specific
bioinformatics capability that is not
available on any other platform
the second is really around the
robustness of the technology
and you know the way we manufacture the
arrays
allows for the batch sizes of the
the batches to be consistent so there
are no snips
dropped across any particular batch and
this is extremely important when you're
looking at gradients
in pharmacogenomics or even variants
that could have highest exercises
that you know would have implications
in how the disease is managed in the
future
um you know we've we've run ourselves
examples here and we've seen
other platforms drop important markers
just across you know a couple of
thousand samples
so really the robustness of the platform
the
the data that comes out the coverage of
the populations and then more
specifically
the markers and areas of
um of the disease and
and traits such as pharmacogenomics is
extremely important this is what you
know
one reason why customers have selected
the axiom platform for all of these
large studies
that have mentioned here and more
great thank you shantanu and we have
time for one last question here
uh do you think uh in low resource
big population countries uh that these
microarray solutions can be implied
uh can be applied on a mass scale for
screening and diagnosis
um certainly yes and you know we um
you know there is plenty of partnerships
that are being that you know we're
working with very closely met genome is
a great exam
the idea here is really to do this cost
effectively
and in our lifetimes right so when we
screen these populations
the goal is really to be able to extract
the genetic information
and make the decisions or changes in
lifestyle based on the findings from our
genetic
profiles they're really serving well
from a large scale perspective
and you know this is the same thing is
true for finjan
also taiwan which i didn't mention uh
you know is
again a good example where we um
have employed the platform across the
country
great thank you very much shantanu and
thank you for the presentation and
answering those questions as well thank
you ryan
so next up we have dr kang wong hong
who is the director division of
healthcare innovation
at theragen bio in south korea serotonin
bio have been conducting genomic
research
and offer genome-based testing services
today he will be
sharing uh theriogens experience and
transitioning from the applied
biosystems open array platform
to the axiom microarray platform and how
theragen partnered with thermofisher to
develop the ferrogen
pmra chip for genetic testing services
welcome dr hong
[Music]
um
okay
um
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
so
um
um
foreign
um
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
um
foreign
foreign
um
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
a
[Music]
foreign
what
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
so
foreign
foreign
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
the python is
thank you for the great presentation dr
hong we have a number of questions
coming through now
from the audience and first up
how are turnaround times of open array
service and microarray service different
from sample to report
oh that is good question and
during the seminar optionally format was
introduced
we usually use 64 format open array
and the experiment starts when we have
at least
48 samples so
overall option rsrbs requires maximum
two weeks
including sample collecting time
but however for microwave
the experiment starts when we have at
least
96 samples so it takes
longer time to correct the samples than
open resources
therefore for this region microarray
service needs
minimum two weeks
thank you for that another question we
have here
phylogenetic analysis was very
interesting
are you providing the genetic testing
service by using phylogenetic analysis
data
we are conducting the research
collaboration
for pyrogenetic analysis
and with the research of this research
we intellectual
property large and then we are planning
to
provide the genetic testing service
maybe in next year yes
great thank you um
i think call rate can be affected by
diverse factors such as sample
population characters and so on what do
you
especially focus on for increasing call
rate up to 99
is it a korean population specific snip
set
it is the important question and
actually there was more effect
for example or population characters
correlate was increased by using upgrade
library pi
for genotype cluster
so with the origin method of genotype
collector
the sample which is out of recording
area
shows the course so first we
optimized core area in order to
decrease the rate of global core
thank you and we have time for one more
question here
uh midi fit nutrition service uh sorry
midi fit and nutrition service
uh look good to manage health and eating
habits
do you provide food allergy information
as well
uh i'm sorry i missed the last part of
your question so could you tell me
okay yeah not a problem the question was
midi fit and nutrition services uh look
great to manage health and eating habits
do you also provide food allergy
information as well
uh yeah there are lots of
the data from abroad but
we don't have enough local data
about food allergies so
therefore it is possible to provide
overseas services but that's for korea
great thank you very much for that dr
hong um
if you did have a question there that
wasn't answered we will reply to you
uh by email and answer your question as
well
so our last speaker for the day is dr
richard pither from japan
dr pitha is the ceo of cytox
and the cytox group of companies provide
non-invasive
risk assessment and patient
stratification tools for alzheimer's
disease
and dementia dr pitha will be speaking
to us about the utility of polygenic
risk scores
for identifying individual genetic risk
and disease risk prediction
in alzheimer's disease at both the early
and pre-symptomatic stages of the
disease
welcome dr pitha hello
my name is richard pither i'm the ceo of
cytox and i'm
speaking today about polygenic risk
score and
the potential in alzheimer's disease for
clinical trial design and the
optimization of clinical trial design
i'd like to give a little bit of an
introduction to alzheimer's disease and
then talk more generally about
polygenic risk scores and how they can
be used
specifically in the context of
alzheimer's disease genetics
and data that we published recently
in the longitudinal analysis of one of
the
very important alzheimer's study cohorts
and what this have the implications for
this type of approach to the clinical
trial enrichment
and clinical risk management for
alzheimer's disease patients ultimately
so alzheimer's disease today affects uh
over 46 million people worldwide and
this figure is set to double by 2030
largely due to the aging population
around the world
current techniques are highly invasive
very expensive and actually have
relatively poor accuracy
and we'll talk a bit more about those
techniques later cytox
is developing a polygenic risk or we
call genus score
and this is a genomic test for assessing
future risk of developing alzheimer's
disease
and in particular the cognitive decline
associated with that disease
it's a relatively simple test requiring
genomic dna
which can come from either blood or
saliva
uh we extract genomic dna run this on
a proprietary uh genotyping
array that we call variate which is a
bespoke array built for us by thermo
fisher
on the axiom platform and that array is
read
in the gene titan instrument and
basically 500 000 data points emanate
from that analysis
that primary genotyping data is then
read by
our snip fitter software and that
generates the genus score report
for each subject and we analyze
essentially 96 samples with each run
and we've worked around the world with
partners in the us in the form of a
keysogen
in europe with europeans and in
australia with the ramashotti center so
we've
this is a robust platform that can be
used
with any laboratory partner that runs
that
genetic axiom platform
now late on to alzheimer's disease
represents the majority of alzheimer's
disease
something like 98 and it has a very
complex etiology
in this illustration here we can see
that effectively the genetic risk for
alzheimer's disease is
an inherited risk and it's fixed
throughout your lifetime
but whether or not someone develops
alzheimer's disease
is a function of the environment and the
lifestyle risk factors that individual
encounters as well as their genetics
so we can see here that cardiovascular
risk
diet exercise the presence of diabetes
neuroinflammatory processes can all
affect the
time and the extent to which the
cognitive decline and other symptoms
associated with alzheimer's disease
become manifest
and we know from identical genetic twin
studies
that these environmental factors have a
major impact on when
or whether an individual is likely to
succumb to alzheimer's disease so in
other words
genetics can explain part of the risk
but like
management of lifestyle and
environmental factors and risks are very
important
for alzheimer's disease clinical
management as well
on this slide we we can see that some of
the biomarkers in
use today have
really changed quite profoundly the way
we think about
alzheimer's disease on the left-hand
side of this chart
on the graphic we can see that
individuals uh start declining
um with late onset alzheimer's disease
symptoms you know from about 60
or 65 years onwards but it becomes
it can be very unclear whether or not
that cognitive change those symptoms are
due to
normal healthy aging or whether there's
underlying alzheimer's pathology
developing in the brain
in the form of the amyloid plaque and
the neurophilic fibrillary tangles and
the neuritic plaques
we know now from imaging and
histopathological studies that this
pathology can actually start
maybe 20 or 30 years before clinical
symptoms so that provides a fantastic
opportunity a window within which
therapies may be administered to prevent
the
ultimate manifestation of alzheimer's
disease
now the way that we look for these
pathologies today
can be very invasive and very expensive
so
amyloid imaging using positron emission
tomography or pet
has taken off really in the last five to
ten years
and really transformed our understanding
but is really of limited
routine clinical use the other option is
to look for
the presence of amyloid and how
fragments in the cerebral spinal fluid
using lumbar puncture
and this obviously carries its own risks
and uh has
soon so far limited uh clinical
application
uh we work at cytotox very closely for
professor john hardy a world-renowned
geneticist and he's of the view as we
are the genetic analysis is
basically the way to provide the most
cost-effective and reliable
stratification of subjects at highest
risk
now alzheimer's disease genetics is
complex
it involves the presence of dna variants
across the genome by far the most
important genetic variant identified so
far
is that associated with the apo eg
apolipo protein e but we can see on this
manhattan plot that
there are uh a fairly large number more
than 40
variants across the genome that reach
genome-wide significance level
uh either in the the context of risk
association
or indeed protection for later on to
alzheimer's disease
so we need to take all these into
account when we're bringing together
apologetic risk score
so we've worked closely with a number of
collaborators around the world and
indeed with the team at thermo fisher
to put together 500 000 markers
all of which have um a degree of
association with risk or protection for
alzheimer's disease
so you can see we've divided on this
graphic
the content of our array
into various different panels including
group including work that's emanated
from the group at ucl
university of birmingham the so-called
mtor panel the very important cardiff
university panel which we'll talk about
in a moment
and then some other content from um
non-alzheimer related neurological
conditions
as well as the early onset dominantly
inherited
alzheimer mutations as well
so it's a very comprehensive array we
believe it's the most comprehensive
genetic array
developed so far for alzheimer's disease
risk association now i mentioned the
cardiff university
content on that array and that's very
important we've worked very closely
over a few years with professors
valentine rescot price and julie
williams and their teams at cardiff
because we believe they have the most
effective polygenic risk score algorithm
so far developed for alzheimer's disease
you can see some of the characteristics
here so
the the algorithm was trained on
the eye gap so called igap consortium
data
which involves 17 000 alzheimer cases
and 37 controls
and in the paper referenced here
valentina
basically published seven and a half
thousand snips which best described
alzheimer's risk
in fact we've moved this work on now
with valentino and her team
and we use 114 000 snips from the array
in our analysis and you can see here
that the
work published uh initially um
with valentina showed a an 84
accuracy in predicting uh alzheimer's
disease in
one particular cohort in this paper but
there's
been subsequent validation of this work
in several other cohorts as well
now very importantly there are
a number of polygenic risk or algorithms
that have been published from different
academic groups around the world
and in 2018 there was a review
of the relative merits and performance
of each of those algorithms
and it's very clear from this paper
authored by hannah stocker and
colleagues
that the cardiff university polygenic
risk or algorithm which is the basis
of our cytotox genoscope polygenic risk
approach
was the best performing and therefore
that's
the reason that we chose that as the
basis for our commercial product
development
now a little bit about before we before
we go into some data
a little bit about alzheimer genetics we
mentioned the apoe the apolipoprotein e
gene earlier and it comes in several
genetic forms
predominantly e2 e3 and e4
and of course every individual carries
two copies of that gene
um we can see on the right hand side
here that um
about 25 percent of the population
um carry one or more copies of
the e4 allele and e4 has an alzheimer
risk association
certainly if you carry 2 copies you're
elevated risk
if you carry a single copy you're
considered to be at higher risk than
average
but there are lots of people who carry
e4
who will never go on to develop
alzheimer's disease
so it's important that any polygenic
risk or consideration
includes an e4 component but they're
also
important that we can also differentiate
between high and low risk even amongst
the e4 carriers
conversely the the bulk of the
population don't carry e4 at all so we
can see here
in this publication from the uk that
about 60 percent of individuals
carrying the e3 e3 homozygote
profile and that they're considered to
be a moderate level of risk
um and and yet we know that about 40
45 percent of alzheimer's sufferers come
from this
non-e4 carrying e3 homozygote group
so it's important that we can stratify
for risk amongst those individuals
just to add to the complexity if we
carry a copy of e2
then e2 is a relatively low risk allele
for
alzheimer's disease so if you were an e4
e2
heterozygote you would carry a lower
than normal risk for
alzheimer's disease development complex
genetics
so what are the benefits potentially of
being able to assess
individuals for alzheimer's disease
using this polygenic risk or approach
and i've listed
several of those opportunities here but
there are others of course
i mean the obvious one is by identifying
clinical trial participants that are
most likely to decline cognitively
within the context or the time frame of
that clinical trial
we're likely to be able to to use
reduced subject numbers and therefore
lower cost approaches to clinical trial
recruitment thereby increasing the
chances
of demonstrating a therapeutic effect
which tends to be done using cognitive
test measures
we have to show that the advantage of
apologetic risk or over and above just
using apoe genotyping alone for the
reasons i just described
and of course what we're really
interested is understanding whether we
can predict those at highest risk of
cognitive decline
not just for clinical trial enrichment
but also for optimizing clinical care
ultimately
a final advantage of this type of
approach is that you can
begin to understand genetic profile that
may link to
specific molecular pathways which would
allow you
potentially to identify those most
likely to benefit
or indeed not benefit from one
particular therapeutic intervention
as a real personalized medicine
opportunity
so we've done much of our analysis for
genus score
in the so-called adney data set acne is
the alzheimer's disease neuroimaging
initiative
and this is a longitudinal study that's
still running today
it's been running for over 15 years
headed by professor mike weiner
at the university of california san
francisco
and what we've done is used
data from about 630
subjects confirmed to with using
amyloid imaging to contain alzheimer's
contain amyloid in the brain so they
would be considered to be at higher risk
of alzheimer's disease
and then we've used also um amyloid
negative controls
so we've got well-matched age groups
we've got
an apoe genotype prevalence that would
be normal for
caucasian cases and controls and we've
used this very rich data set to analyze
the performance
of our genetic polygenic risk or
approach
so a little bit of data now on the next
couple of slides
so what we can see here if we just
concentrate um
on the highlighted area the red
highlighted area
we can see that if we use applewee alone
across this
adney cohort we have an auc
of about 73 percent um
if we use the prs alone without the
apoe component we're at 70 if we combine
the two together
we get to about 80 percent which is a
very good
level of accuracy in describing
biomarker confirmed
alzheimer cases from age matched
biomarker negative controls
so that's very encouraging what we'd
really like to know
is whether we can stratify the subjects
in the e4
or indeed the non-e4 carrier group so
what we did here
on this page is we looked at the
distribution of polygenic risk scores
in the e3 e4 heterozygote so these would
be considered
just by apoe genotype alone to be at
relatively high risk
but we can see on the right hand side
that there's a distribution of polygenic
risk scores all the way from zero
to to one one being the highest and
um if we ask uh if we apply a cut off a
polygenic risk or cut off here
of about point six we can see a positive
predictive value
of around eighty four percent in
identifying genuine
80 carriers at this or ad risk subjects
within this universally high risk cohort
conversely if we look at the e3 e3
homozygous who would be considered to be
at low risk of alzheimer's disease
and again here we apply a cut-off at the
low to to
remove the lowest quartile we have a
negative predictive value of about 89
whereas if you apply a higher quartile
cut off
you you you improve uh to about 51
the positive predictive value so you can
see here um
the the opportunity to enrich for the
highest and lowest risk individuals
regardless of their apple e4 status and
this has not been
possible genetically before before now
now as i said earlier the real prize
here is
is to be able to predict those
individuals at very early stages
of cognitive decline who are most likely
to decline
further over the course of a clinical
trial period usually
up to four years so here what we've done
is taken
baseline individuals with so-called mci
or mild cognitive impairment
and then we've asked how many of those
people have changed significantly
using a cognitive rating scale called
adas cog
over the next four years and how
accurately could we have predicted
those at highest risk of cognitive
decline so you can see here of the 285
mci baseline individuals 61
cases declined by
10 points or more over a four year
period which is considered clinically
significant
whereas 224 remain stable
and that we were able to identify with
an auc in accuracy of about 74
uh those at highest risk of cognitive
decline just using a polygenic risk
approach
this is highly uh interesting data
and then if we look at that that group
slightly more closely on the left-hand
side here
you can see that the uh the distribution
of adas called decline mimics very
nicely or matches very nicely
the polygenic risk score so on the
x-axis we can see
polygenic risk ranging from zero to one
and we can see that those with the
highest degree of decline 15 points are
bunched up towards the right hand end of
this graphic the highest polygenic risk
scores
the lowest of five points or or fewer
are distributed mainly to the left as
you would have expected
and those who decline by 5 to 15 points
intermediate level
again have a nice rightward shift in
this distribution
showing this link between polygenic risk
score
and cognitive decline over a four year
period
if we look on the right hand side of
this graphic we can see that um
the apo e4 homozygotes the
people colored in red are the highest
endoplasmic risk score spectrum as we
would have expected
those that carry one copy of e4 in
yellow are distributed
um towards the right hand side but you
can see there are plenty of
relatively lower risk individuals that
carry e4
and the e3 e3 homozygotes again
distributed from very low polygenic risk
to much higher polygenic risk
again illustrating the fact that it's
that you're able to identify
those at highest risk of developing the
disease amongst the
e3 e3 homozygotes
so in conclusion we have been able to
show that
we can stratify for e4 carriers
at the highest risk of developing
alzheimer's disease
and conversely we can also stratify the
e3
homozygotes at the highest and lowest
end the risk spectrum for developing
alzheimer's disease and this is really
of critical importance both to pharma
companies
looking to stratify clinical trial
populations
and of course also clinicians who want
to understand
risk in their in their subjects
the algorithm has the potential to
improve the ability to predict those
with early
mild cognitive impairment who are at
highest risk of developing alzheimer's
disease
and this is an improvement over using
apoe genetics alone
and of course this would allow you to
select
subjects at the highest risk and the
most likely
to decline in the context of a clinical
trial
time frame thereby allowing a very
valuable enrichment opportunity
i mentioned also that we have
an approach looking at pathway analysis
and importantly our genoscore
algorithm we will are launching as a
clear ldt uh um
[Music]
assay in the u.s later this year and as
a ce marked product
in europe also by the end of this year
and this is really important because um
the the last 20 years has been very
unsuccessful
in identifying new therapies for
alzheimer's treatment but
there's some very promising new drugs
coming forward now
at the front of that pack is ajikanomab
being developed by biogen
biogen presented some very interesting
new analysis
of their clinical studies at the end of
last year
and they're currently in discussion with
the fda about um
resubmitting this for approval
uh during the second half of 2020
with the expectation that there may be
some kind of
approval uh you know a year or 18 months
after that so
the opportunity for treatment
and improved treatment for for patients
is
is becoming more reality so it's
important that the testing
keeps keeps pace with that finally
i would like to thank my colleagues in
cytox for
much of the the work and the analysis
that i presented today
and also pay tribute to our scientific
partners
particularly at the dementia research
institutes at cardiff university
the team's led by valentino scott price
and julie williams
the ucl team led by professor john hardy
and also the university of exeter team
led by professor
clive ballard i'd also like of course to
acknowledge adney
an act for access to their data and
colleagues at
thermo fisher who've provided a lot of
technical guidance
over the course of this work and finally
as well as our investors inside talks
we've also received funding from
innovate uk
uh here in in in oxford
and also from the european union through
the horizon 2020 research program
thank you for your attention
i would like to thank dr pitter for his
presentation today and i do need to
correct that uh dr peter and cytox are
uk based rather than in japan as i
previously stated so my apologies for
that max up
dr pitha was unable to join us live
today
but he has prepared some answers to
questions that had come up earlier
and if you have any additional questions
from that presentation please feel free
to send this through and we'll do our
best to answer them now or pass this
along to dr pepper as well for
his attention
what do you think the practical limits
of polygenic risk scores
for risk stratification will be in
routine use
so as i mentioned earlier the
alzheimer's disease
has both a genetic and an environmental
and lifestyle risk component
we've done much work to understand the
limits
of polygenic risk scores relate onto
alzheimer's disease
and we believe that the polygenic risk
or algorithm
uh which has a an upper limit of
accuracy of around 85 percent
is performing at that level now so we
think that the polygenic risk
approach that we've adopted effectively
takes into account
all the genetic variation that will be
contributing to risk in an individual
but of course the time and the severity
of the symptoms in any one individual
will also be impacted by lifestyle and
environmental risk exposure
over the course of an individual's
lifetime
how has your polygenic risk score been
validated has there been any independent
verifications
so our polygenic risk or algorithm has
been validated in
multiple data sets um the cardiff
university
group on which our algorithm is based
has been validated in a number of
longitudinal
very well characterized samples
three or four independent verification
data sets
including individuals who
went on to die and then we were able to
look at post-mortem
histopathology confirmation in alzheimer
cases and age match controls
and that's a sort of gold standard
approach to validating
polygenic risk or algorithms and the in
fact the
the performance of the algorithm in that
particular study
was at something like 86 or 87 percent
which we think is at the theoretical
maximum for this type of
apologetic risk or approach
how do you design your axiom array to
make it as effective as possible for
polygenic risk or analysis
in ad
so we've designed the axiom array and
the we covariate
to contain the
ideal snip combination to run the
polygenic risk score
the genoscore analysis that as i
mentioned in my
presentation includes 114 000
snips or dna variants that are optimized
for the
cardiff algorithm or genoscore approach
and then we have a lot of other content
which allows us to do other forms of
analysis
including identifying individuals with
the
early onset high risk dna variants or
mutations
in protein in one prisonalin ii an
amyloid precursor protein
which we use as a quality control step
to make sure that
we're not dealing with an early onset
case
as we do our analyses we also
have dna variants associated with
other non-alzheimer disease dementias on
the array
again that allows us to broaden the type
of analysis we can do
in any one data set
who are the key potential customers for
your polygenic risk score
potential customers for our prs approach
today
include both academics and pharma
companies
pharma companies obviously are driven by
the need to
stratify the individuals at
highest risk into their clinical studies
so that they can optimize cohort
selection
for demonstrating therapeutic effects of
their particular
interventions be they pharmacological
new drugs
or other types of interventions so we've
been working with a number of those
companies over the last couple of years
also academics are interested in
understanding genetic and non-genetic
factors for alzheimer's disease risk and
so we work with
various academics to help them
understand
genetic risk profiles within their own
cohort their own longitudinal subject
cohorts
do you envision your array and software
going through a
510k regulatory approval
so our array and software which together
comprise
the ginator product are
we've been in discussion with the fda in
the us
for a few weeks we've decided
with their advice that we will pursue
initially
the approval and launch of a clear
ldt or laboratory developed test service
in the us with various lab partners
and in europe we will go down the ce
marked route and that allows us to get
this product
available to a very high quality
standard
by the end of this year for the u.s and
europe
and but beyond that we will be doing
the formal clinical validation studies
that would support a 510
510 k regulatory process and approval
uh in the us and and in europe
and we would imagine um envisage
starting those studies
later this year and then being the
position to to file for regulatory
approval
sometime during 2021
and that's the end of the live q a uh
for dr pipper's presentation i really
want to thank all of our speakers for
their time
uh and efforts today and for everyone
listening for the questions as well
this concludes the webinar sessions for
today but the environment will remain
live and open so please drop by our
booth and speak to us
and find out more about the solutions
that we have to help accelerate your
research
please also participate in a scavenger
hunt game look out for icons in the
environment to win some cool prizes
there will be a pop-up survey appearing
in a minute please
complete this to help us
evaluate this roadshow and thank you
again
for all of your attendance